we ask that you bless this beautiful
bridge today so that we will may well
use it we we ask that you bless those
who created at those who designed it and
those who will use it more like it torn
you up to forever and ever we have first
three speakers each supported by a way
outta from the council's why out a group
we will hear from matt do see who's the
Member of Parliament for waimakariri
then mark yaxley from New Zealand
Transport Agency and then mayor david
ayers the Waimakariri district council
was widely regarded as one of the best
in New Zealand especially for their
leadership during the earthquakes end in
the recovery the result of their
leadership is this new outstanding
Ashley bridge but today we can say that
bridge closures due to flooding will
only be a distant memory
bridges play a vital role in connecting
our communities the old bridge has done
that very well for 103 years I'm sure
you'll all agree this marvelous new
structure will see us well for probably
a very long time as a cyclist I'm really
tickled thing to see that this bridge
includes a cycleway and a foot way I
think as a community that gives you
great opportunities to think about
commuting and recreation and there's
even business opportunities out of that
it takes a team of people to build a
bridge to focus for the team has been
get the new bridge built as quickly as
possible with as little impact as
possible we have built a strong bridge
but more importantly we've helped to
build make our community stronger to
improve the connections between both
sides of this river I believe that
building communities is an important
council function and this bridge is a
manifestation of that so welcome to this
new bridge cure cutter so now we come to
the official opening the chairman of the
Ashley County at the time the old bridge
was opened was William Mackintosh and
his wife Jeanne cut the ribbon to a eat
today we have their great-grandson Neil
still farming on that white rock farm
here to cut the ribbon and what as I
announced the opening and he is using
exactly the same pair of scissors used
in 1912